hello there guys hope you're doing well
so in this video we're going to be
speaking about the acolyte which is an
upcoming star wars tv show which will be
released
on disney plus so for some context the
acolyte is set to take place in the
final days of the high republic era a
period roughly 200 years before the
events of the phantom menace so anyway
there was a new interview released
regarding this tv show with the creator
headline who was the co-creator
of russian doll so without further ado
let's get into the interview
so headland says what i can say is the
reason it did appeal to me personally is
that i was 18 when phantom menace came
out
and i was a very very big star wars fan
i remained a big star wars fan then this
big
huge movie event cultural event happened
that was the phantom menace
she continued and i know there were
varying reactions too but i was very
intrigued why george lucas had started
us at that particular point
i kind of wondered what happened to lead
up to this that's kind of where my style
was fan brain went
was like how did we get here why are the
jedi like this
when were they in power why are they
acting this way and how is it that
they're not having the reaction that you
would think that would be anakin's
presence and what qui-gon jinn is saying
about how
passionately he feels about training him
and bringing him into the fold so if we
look at the acolyte in the perspective
of the star wars timeline where all the
movies and tv shows are set so dark
light would be the very
first entry into the star wars saga
because currently it's the phantom
menace but as we know
this show is set before that so i think
this leaves us a big enough gap for a
lot of
our creative freedom or it will give us
a very good opportunity to further
cement the foundation of the phantom
menace and how things are in that movie
such as we could explore the rule of two
and how that came into play or further
explore the idea
of the chosen one prophecy or how the
jedi came into power
also this show is actually going to
focus on the dark side which is really
exciting to me because i've been wanting
to see something from the perspective
of darkseid for such a long time anyway
let's continue with the interview most
of the people that i met with were
people that were either really big fans
of the franchise but maybe not as
familiar with dave filoni's work in
clone wars and hadn't played the video
games
and then there were people like myself
that i've watched all of clone wars and
played fallen order
knights of old republic and also done a
lot of rpgs including
edge of the empire so i kind of felt
like i was very into star wars
now i know there's been a lot of
controversy surrounding the show
and how the show is going to end up like
and i'm not going to go into that stuff
but honestly
after reading this interview i'm
actually really excited for the show i
feel like
this is such an unexplored era of star
wars
and i feel like she's actually a really
big star wars fan she's played the games
she's watched clone wars
she's even done some rpgs like edge of
the empire
she seems like a star wars fan which is
good that's what you want for people
making their shows like dave filoni and
john favreau they're massive star wars
fans look how the mandalorians turned
out so yeah i think the acolyte arm has
the potential to be really good so i
think we should all go into
an open mind and see how things play out
like you know we haven't even seen a
trailer or anything yet
so um yeah i'm excited for the show tell
me what you guys think in the comment
section below
would you like to see the return of
characters such as yoda or even
appearances of characters like darf
plagueis
[Music]
foreign